Today,
I'm going to read a passage
from the book Munich.
By Robert Harris.
Legat took out a large,
white cotton handkerchief
and wiped his face.
It would not do
to turn up red faced
and perspiring.
If there was one sin
that was frowned upon
above all others
in the private office,
it was appearing
to be in a flap.
He climbed the steps
into the narrow, shadowed,
soot-black, and cutting
of Downing Street.
On the pavement
opposite Number 10,
a group of reporters
turned their heads
to follow his arrival.
A photographer
raised his camera,
but when he saw
it was no one of importance,
he lowered it again.
Legat nodded
to the policeman
who wrapped once hard
with the knocker.
The door opened
as if of its own volition.
He stepped inside.
It was four months
since he had been seconded
from the foreign office
to work in Number 10,
yet each time
he felt that same sensation
as if he was entering
some gentleman's club
that was no longer
fashionable.
The black
and white-tiled lobby,
the walls of Pompeiian red,
the brass lantern,
the grandfather clock
ticking
its leisurely heartbeat.
Somewhere in the depths
of the building,
a telephone rang.
The doorkeeper wished Legat
a good afternoon
and returned to
his leather coachman's seat
and his copy
of the Evening Standard.
In the wide passageway
leading
to the back of the building,
Legat paused and checked
himself in the mirror.
He straightened his tie
and smoothed down his hair
with both hands.
He braced his shoulders
and turned.
Ahead of him
was the cabinet room,
its panelled door closed.
To his left,
the office
used by Sir Horace Wilson,
also closed.
To his right, the corridor
that led to the offices
of the prime minister's
private secretaries.
The Georgian house
exuded an air
of imperturbable calm.
Chamberlain took his seat
behind the microphone
and spread out his speech.
His hands were shaking.
One of the pages
fell to the floor
and he had to bend stiffly
to retrieve it.
He muttered
and wobbling
all over the place.
He asked
for a glass of water.
Legat poured one
from the jug
in the centre of the table.
In his anxiety,
he overfilled it.
Beads of water stood out
on the polished surface.
The BBC engineer
asked them all to sit
at the other end
of the room.
Outside, over the garden
and horse guards parade,
darkness had fallen.
Big Ben
chimed eight o'clock.
The announcers voice
came over the loud speaker.
This is London.
In a moment,
you will hear
the prime minister,
the Right Honourable
Neville Chamberlain,
speaking
from Number 10 Downing St.
His speech will be heard
all over the empire,
throughout the continent
of America,
and in a large number
of foreign countries.
Mr Chamberlain.
Beside the microphone,
a green light glowed.
The prime minister
adjusted his cuffs
and picked up his speech.
I want to say
a few words to you,
men and women of Britain
and the empire.
And perhaps,
to others as well.
His tone was euphonious,
melancholy,
as inspiring as a dirge.
-Slam. All you'll get.
-Yeah. Yeah.
That's all you'll get.